bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa dj oggi
iniziamo finalmente una nuova serie
horror
scusatemi ragazze ultimamente non ho
fatto praticamente horror al di fuori di
penombra
ma veramente stavano aspettando che
uscisse lander di arrivo in modo da
iniziare dopo questo anche tutti gli
altri oro che avevo in mente di fare ci
tengo a precisare prima di iniziare che
questa non è la serie horror che avrei
dovuto fare diciamo come se quel ad è
granché come avevo detto alla fine di
the grudge ma quello è un altro horror
ancora che devo iniziare prima o poi lo
farò state tranquilli
questo è proprio un altra serie a parte
avevo fatto già la beta di questo
videogame circa un mesetto fa ma era
soltanto praticamente la modalità prendi
le auto pagine prima che lo slang al di
stupri questo è il gioco ufficiale
uscito ieri 27 marzo
allora c'è stage selection che sarebbe
la possibilità di scegliere gli stage
noi e nella beta avevamo fatto soltanto
di aids page che era ovviamente prendere
l'auto pagine quindi direi di iniziare
con la modalità storia perfetto
vai celle ok c'è una montagna già da
subito
raga sono prontissimo iniziare il primo
vero slider cioè non so che cosa mi
troverò davanti non ha la più pallida
idea
vi devo spaventarmi non lo so ora c'è
una macchina
siamo partiti subito bene
ok c'è una macchina dispersa nei posti
spesso siamo guidati dalla nostra
devozione la nostra more dal nostro
affetto
ok le frasi di offerte iniziali già mi
colpiscono o che c'è una macchina non
sta a bond james bond
vista frase sinceramente non ci ho
capito un cazzo ma andiamo avanti
cioè che cazzo quando trovi testa quando
ti trovi da solo lui niente come al
solito non riesco a leggere un cazzo è
quanto riuscirà ad andare lontano prima
che ti prenda non lo so siamo partiti
siamo partiti ragazzi evento incredibile
primissimo video game oro nella storia
primo in cui si capisce come ci siamo
finiti qui primo raga io ci farei un
monumento soltanto per questo
allora praticamente stanno mandando in
macchina e vabbè è caduto sto albero
alla macchina penso si sia scassata e va
beh direi di via di proseguire come
ambientazione vi sembra un po strana
perché diciamo è ok go eyes studio
presence ok
qua ci sono i titoli iniziali come se
fosse un film non ho mai fatto uno slang
alla luce del sole in associaizone with
parsec production raga mi sto calando ed
è soltanto l'intro ma vabbè diciamo raga
che come ambientazione sembra un po la
versione che abbiamo giocato nella beta
però di giorno e ovviamente questo è
soltanto l'intro direi di andare un pò
veloce perché si titoli mi stanno
rompendo il cazzo
ok stiamo andando a ok vedo qualcosa
vedo qualcosa c'è una casa c'è una casa
la vedo in lontananza e stadi 20 sta
diventando buio
raga sta diventando buio sta iniziando a
spaventarmi
ebbene noi sa cos'è quello cos'è è un
cartello tranquilli è soltanto un
cartello io mi spavento per niente cazzo
sta diventando veramente buio
entriamo forse il ok è già stata
comprata perché volevo comprarla io è
perché io non vengo vi venissi posti
fantastici cazzo sta diventando buio
fatemi entrare
fatemi entrare cazzo ok kg la porta left
che i cold and red door shop enclosed ok
che figo e tipo in one si allarga poi
trascinare le porte per chiuderle
fantastico sono dentro sono dentro la
casa di non so ki e ci sono dei disegni
fantastici sul muro ok raga è diventato
ufficialmente buio e ci sono le cose che
cazzo è quella roba che lampeggiavano lo
so è una figata assurda c'è
l'ambientazione l'ambientazione la
migliore finora
e vabbè c'è una traccia c'è una torcia
ho trovato una torcia si ok siamo
partiti benissimo cosa io c'è
l'interferenza c'è l'interferenza ma non
c'è nessuno permesso non c'è nessuno mi
trovano
ok è io dietro non ci vado
chiude anche ragazzi amo in cucina ora
flashlight l'ater batteries cherosene
extra times va bene e c'è il frigo ci
sono già la dispensa come al solito è la
volta che lo aspettavo veramente dov'è
la nutella denise lander ok c'è una
porta penso sia accesso infatti mi si è
chiusa la porta in faccia perché non
posso vedere quanto sono figo la bear
sharon perdere delle kia ho preso delle
chiavi ho preso delle chiavi spero siano
della macchina spero vivamente che siano
della macchina sono continuamente
guardando fuori raga perché ho paura che
mi si punti qualcuno all'improvviso
vabbè facciamo finta di niente c'è
nessuna piano 18 na perfetto abbiamo
controllato tutte le porte raga quasi ne
manca praticamente le mancano due c'è la
stanza da letto perfetto anche queste
vuota mi sembra la casa del film la
madre che ho visto recentemente ed è
inquietante vabbè cos'è quel o di alcun
dame i cold anch'egli avevo anch'io da
piccola che figo
e non lo sapevo che lo salendo giocasse
qui gundam mi prende dei punti sto
ragazzo ok va bene c'è la porta sempre
chiusa fortunatamente direi di andare
nell'ultima stanza
ok l'ultima stanza raga e poi ho
controllato tutto porta aperta permesso
posso ok perfetto cos'è oddio che cazzo
è successo hanno appeso un po di disegni
al muro mi dicono ma che bello esistono
i fogli per disegnare deve essere
passato il bambino di the grudge qui
e vabbè quello che disegnava sui muri
vabbè lasciamo stare e c'è una scrivania
perfetto to the walls nel bosco cosa
vuol dire le bosco che cazzo succede c'è
si aperto il cancello cazzo si è sentito
il ruolo raccapricciante si è aperto il
cancello
ok laga presumo che io debba uscire è
una cosa che non voglio fare ma devo
è perfetto raga mi sto preoccupando
seriamente c'è nessuno
ok io vado matto nel bosco perché ho
trovato giustamente un volantino che mi
diceva di andare nel bosco e io cosa
faccio vado nel bosco perfetto perfetto
fantastica sono ragazza sola ragazza
anche abbastanza gioca va bene direi che
possiamo andare nel bosco raga sono
contentissimo non vedevo l'ora non
vedevo l'ora che questo e quello della
beta e il pezzo dove c'era una beta this
land rock è i
non so se precisamente io debba fare
come nella beta ovvero trovare le pagine
sparse nel caso penso di velocizzarla
raga perché voi l'avete già vista sa
parte in alto a sinistra vi metto
l'annotazione del video che vi porta
diciamo alla parte della beta così vi
vedete anche st parte qui che ho già
fatto così almeno nola ripeto per quelli
che l'hanno già vista allora c'è una
pagina una su otto
io direi di tagliare più che non lo
finisco per questa parte non me la
rifaccio ci sono ragazzi sono ci sono ci
sono 8 su 8 tutti liz lander finora
erano sempre finiti di merda a questo
punto
anche questo finisce male che cazzo
succede ok sto scappando
ok scappa da è stronzo a scappa scappa
oddio no a te faccio mi sono suicidati
non sono ancora vivo che cazzo succede
dove sta andando la perché sto correndo
mi ha preso mi ha preso cosa che cazzo è
successo
ok che cazzo successo sono steso ok sono
mezzo morto ma sono ancora vivo e del
giorno sono sveglio fantastico sono sono
ancora vivo sono io
2 casa dove cazzo son caduto oh mio dio
sono vivo ora che la prima volta che
dopo le otto pagine nella storia di
blender è la prima volta che si
sopravvive
ovviamente la beta comprendeva soltanto
quel pezzettino che io ho tagliato
perché molti di voi avevano già visto
quindi raga da qui in avanti non so
proprio nulla di nulla
direi di proseguire c'è che cos'è una
galleria oddio sto posto al buio e
macabro sembra tipo alla wave
voglio provare ad entrare nella galleria
ma non ho dato ok come non detto l'ho
tirata fuori dalle mutande va beh direi
proseguire a questo punto non sono anche
dove sto andando
salve sto entrando a caso in dei fossi
che non conosco ok ci sono un po di
frecce che cazzo gets the tower ok come
cazzo ci sai quali sopra però sto post
ora che è veramente abnorme c'è una cosa
assurda
e bene direi di che cazzo c'è un bottone
raga penso che serva per alzare sa fare
di elevator his home is on power ed ok
devo dare energia sta roba perché sennò
non funziona
ok oddio 1 su 6 generatori attivati
ma che cazzo oddio la quest'anno poi non
devo raccogliere le pagine cadeva
primare i generatori ok lago ho capito
lo scopo di questo di questo livello
this land air devo praticamente attivare
tutti i generatori per salire sulla
torre
ovviamente ne abbiamo uno su sei devo
trovare gli altri per salire di sopra ok
ok raga l'ora siamo entrati nella nuova
parte this land air che ancora non ha
visto nessuno direi di proseguire non so
dove sta andando non mi chiedete non ne
ho idea c'è un altro generatore perfetto
siamo a due
ok raga lo slang in spazi ristretti è
quello che mi piace di meno perché so
che me lo troverò negli angoli
ok raga l'introduzione è ufficialmente
finita preparatevi perché lo slang di
questo svendere qui è molto ma molto più
pauroso anche della beta e di tutti gli
altri sander che avete visto credetemi è
l'anno proprio anche di fatto la la beta
è molto più alto anche c'è una cosa
assurda poi vedrete
anzi spero che non lo vedrete ma penso
di sì perché è ovviamente impossibile
che non appaia anche se spero con tutto
il mio cuore che non lo faccia ok sono
entrato qui dentro vuoto o che cazzo chi
è questo aiuto che cazzo è sta roba
lo tolga [ __ ] che cazzo era porca
[ __ ]
minchia ma chi era quello di oliva
arrivari periodo di aiuto aiuto aiuto
chi cazzo
oddio oddio no non entrare non entrare
chi cazzo sei non è lo slider questo
ancora peggio ma chi cazzo
è uno stupratore di turno ok raga aiuto
paura che spunti non so chi è ma ecco
perché sto zoppicando dai le muoviti
strazza ho capito che la ragazza in una
galleria abbandonata non è proprio il
massimo ma chi cazzo è quello ok la
palla
aiuta madonna santissima
ma chi cazzo ma quanti sono ragazzo
svendersi sono uniti gli stupratori del
mondo aiuto oddio vuol dire io no
aiuto mi segue mi segue no no no no no
ok è sparito è sparito è sparito è
sparito andiamo o cazzo ma chi cazzo
sono questi questa è la cosa più assurda
che abbia una donna che anzi a raga è la
cosa più assurda che abbia mai giocato
cioè non ho mai visto una cosa del
genere c'è veramente e la cosa penso sia
il personaggio più inquietante di sempre
anche piris lander c'è è inquietante
come non so cosa al fatto che si corra
addosso così raga devo tirare un sospiro
perché veramente mi sto pagando addosso
c'è una c'è un braccio c'è un braccio
corrie ok non posso non posso passare
questo punto merda entrò nella porta qui
a prima che becco perfetto cos'è sta
roba
[Musica]
c'è un'ansia che non ne avete idea
e assurdo sto svenderci
oddio no no no no no no no no no no va
con ricordi corri corri corri corri
corri corri corri corri aiuto aiuto la
via pavia
ok ma cazzo è sempre lì cazzo
no è un vicolo cieco visto fra visto
preiodo no no
fermati ti prego ti danno tutta la
nutella che vuoi ma fermati chi cazzo
sei o mio dio fai piu paura di quella di
the grudge sta fermo ok ora mi avvicino
mi avvicino piano non o cattive
intenzioni ti prego no no aiuto aiuto lo
ha girato ce l'ho fatta ce la sto
facendo cori maledetta stronza corri no
oddio non ci passo non ci passa aiuto
che cazzo [ __ ] [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ok ok ok ho perso questo è in assoluto
il videogioco this lander più
inquietante cambia mai giocato droga
direi di chiudere qui il video perché
veramente era cosa assurda nel prossimo
episodio cercherò di finire questa parte
ovviamente le altre perché la storia
penso sia lunga veramente sono senza
parole
se vi dove è piaciuto lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete accorti
scriveteli noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi